the Joe Rogan experience when I worked
for you know one of these companies they
told me to side with the audience we
talked about it last time I was here
mm-hmm
they wanted me to create a narrative
that the audience agreed with because we
were there to serve them what was the
narrative young progressives whatever
they say
so social justice so whatever young
progressives say in one side with that
and I told him I asked are you saying
that if there is a factual news story
that would be upsetting to audience we
won't cover it he said I think that's
fair yeah what was it that Oh a OC said
recently that people shouldn't go back
to work that they shouldn't revolt like
they should yeah they should protest
like not go back to work that to me was
one of the craziest things I've ever
heard a politician say like if anything
we need to get the goddamn economy back
on track I wonder if she's gonna lose in
her primary she's going up against a
woman named Michelle Caruso Cabrera who
is a moderate who actually sounds very
reasonable and it and it kind of breaks
my heart a bit because I remember how
Democrats used to be I'm like you could
look at the thing she talks about and
she's a very reasonable like she's got
like a book
she was an anchor for some of I think
for like CNBC or something and she comes
off like I don't know kind of like maybe
you were me just how what used to be
left before they went became radical
activists and for social justice why do
you think they went that way
why do you think every social man you
think so yeah so you know there's a
couple different theories I have on it
conservatives are less likely to be
online in a lot of areas of the country
they have weaker internet all right but
they're so active online they dominate
for sure and that's one of the reasons
they're like you know they get wiped out
a lot but you look at really talking
about conservatives yeah yeah
conservatives getting banned a whole lot
because they're very active they do a
lot of memes but I think so how are you
saying that they're less likely to have
good internet rural rural towns
have really bad internet but he's good
enough to be able to post on Twitter
like what do you mean no yes it has
phones but with if you've got dial-up in
the middle of the country you're not
posting a video or a photo you are watch
on your phone you are watching dial-up
yeah that's true one's doing it through
their phones that's a good point
right what I think is that you've got a
lot of older people that are
conservative a lot of younger people
that are liberal and there's there's
issues there with how people interact
online mm-hmm so
my assumptions my opinions things I've
read older people more likely to just
follow and read younger people more
likely to engage most people not likely
to engage at all it's something I think
like 2% of a country action is actually
active on Twitter yeah but you end up
with internal biases the social media
companies who is authoritative and who
isn't that Co chambers so a really good
example is like BuzzFeed news wrote a
story that the wuhan bio lab leak theory
is a right wing you know popular right
wing theory Trump supporters are pushing
it and here's why it's wrong but CNN ran
multiple segments about this and so when
when you have digital media framing
things as always like you you ever
wonder why they never say left wing you
know like in the media will say
conservatives did X they never say
liberals did X because they view
themselves as those people right so you
end up with social media companies that
view that kind of content as
authoritative left-leaning
you end up with left-wing activists and
acceptable marketability there was a
study done where they tracked
essentially like a it's a visualization
of location for various aspects of than
the Internet conservatives are in this
bubble liberals in this bubble marketing
digital marketing companies overlapped
with resistance Twitter anti-trump so
what ends up happening is big marketing
firms based in New York City based in
Los Angeles very urban areas much more
likely to be blue have a blue
perspective they run commercials based
on a left-wing perspective politicians
see with what the television is saying
they see what the websites are saying
and they say this is what America wants
it's not it's what the hyperactive 2% of
Twitter wants so they fall into that
trap where they believe all this stuff
the reason Ocasio cortez became got
elected she won I think seven 17,000
votes in a district of 750,000 like
that's not winning a real election but I
was an exploit it was exploiting the
system so you end up with someone who
has views that don't represent the
overwhelming majority of this country in
a very high-profile position influencing
Nancy Pelosi and what you know one of
the reasons they think they even went
for with impeachment was because Ocasio
Cortes gave a statement where she said
it was a bigger scandal that the
Democrats would not impeach Trump next
thing we know Nancy Pelosi hops on board
with the idea and that blew up in their
face
Trump ends up seeing his approval rating
go up he raises a ton of money it would
be really interesting if what
did him in was the Lysol [ __ ] oh that
was bad for him though yeah but I don't
think yeah I don't think it'll be it
what do you think is gonna happen in
November as of right now there's the
panic factor could be good for Trump the
fact that we're in a crisis may mean
people are desperate for security and
they don't want to take a chance they
don't take any chances and Trump is a
bully like I don't mean it necessarily
as like you know to the Trump supporters
get mad what I mean is like he's he
pushes people around and a lot of people
like that about him that he yells at the
press what a lot of people on the Left
don't get is when he yelled at that CNN
guy you're a nasty reporter his base was
clapping standing up saying thank you
for finally calling these people out
right it was a good thing you take that
attitude next to Biden do you think
Biden's gonna make anybody feel safe nah
man I don't think so so the the argument
I've put forward is look man I'm a
moderate person my politics have always
been left-leaning pro-choice progressive
tax government programs all this good
stuff grew up in a city but I'm not
super far left I need an argument from
you Donald Trump has come forward with
the economy was booming loss
unemployment in 50 years best numbers of
our lives up until the pandemic he
instituted a travel ban that they adapt
the Democrats are even agreeing with not
this point if you want to convince me to
vote for you and many people like me I
think you got to give me an argument as
to why Biden is better but they're not
they're saying stay alive Joe Biden we
just don't like Trump but they really
they really are they're really doing
that it's a good point and I think if
the economy does manage to show some
signs of resurgence around November in
in you know towards October in September
if he has some sort of a real rock-solid
plan and he can show you where it's
going this is what we're planning on
doing this we're gonna have this by that
and that by this by the way Joe Biden is
not going to get better his cognitive
decline is going to increase and he
kidding it could drop right off of a
[ __ ] cliff you might come around to
where November is where the gaffes are
constant and they pull him off of the
public eye and they never show him if
the Democrats want to win they'll run
Michelle Obama we might have a [ __ ]
CGI Joe Biden with I'm not kidding where
he does it from some sort of a remote
location and they CGI the [ __ ] out of
his his face well I'll tell you one
thing that
there's there's some net positive Trump
could look at in terms of the pandemic
worry
you know people trust him his approval
rating was going up when they were
televising his his press briefings as
soon as they stopped doing that as proof
writing start going back down so when
people hear what he was saying they
liked it but the other big factor is if
this persists beyond the election Joe
Biden will never debate him and we see
this in the press right now everyone
keeps saying it the more the longer Joe
Biden is hidden the batter his campaign
is doing because people can't see him
struggling the speaker just going
against Trump mail-in voting I agree
with you about Michelle Obama but I
don't think she really wants to run well
I didn't I'm not sure she would either
but I'm saying that's their I think they
would win if they ran her they probably
would mail and voting I think will be
the downfall Republicans if if mail-in
voting does get pushed through Nancy
Pelosi I believe she said she wants to
have mail-in voting confirmed the next
stimulus package if the lockdown
persists beyond November November and
mail-in voting is the go-to way the the
challenge you see a bunch of Republicans
saying that mail-in voting could lead to
fraud and it can right if somebody's mom
is like you know old and just like not
paying attention and you fill it out for
her but the bigger issue I see for
Republicans is that uninitiated and
uninterested people will be voted for
and that means in big urban areas you'll
have a mom and a dad telling their kids
who normally don't care to vote just
fill it out just fill it out just vote
for the guy and that could potentially
hurt I thumped the real concern is in
the counting that's the concern but in
terms of fraud right fraud is so the
Republicans main concern is fraud then
someone's gonna take their kids pack in
just fill out for them right but I don't
think not just that also in how it's
counted right tracking them they'll go
to mailbox and the post office so a mess
I agree with all that no I think I think
you don't need to go so far as to assume
someone's going to snatch up all the
ballots it's possible and replace them I
think that's a bit too much for me
I just think right now we know the youth
vote swings left and they don't care
about voting you put the ballot in their
house they don't they didn't turn out
for Bernie they did not turn out they
turned out in some areas but they didn't
turn out so you get this very active
base online ranting about what they want
they don't actually go out for it put
the bat in their pocket send it to their
mailbox and their mom says there it is
fill it out they're gonna do it and so
that's gonna make sure the people who
normally aren't bothered to go vote will
go vote
[Applause]